I always get nervous for every single
show I had horrible stage fright before
I got up and would do stand up I used to
I used to think was less embarrassing
when I would tell the stories like
before my just for last audition I went
backstage and I threw up but the truth
is I wouldn't throw up I would just I
would have explosive poops yes but but
it was more masculine
[Laughter]
yeah exactly yeah not a good look
probably this guy after all that cocaine
right yeah yeah Vinnie doesn't need to
get it moving it's hard for you to shed
that but you still get nervous when you
do shows that's what you're saying still
even a show like this you're nervous
right here and then when did the nerves
go away never so you're nervous right
now I'm nervous right now don't do what
you typically do before a show right now
please yeah well you know what it is
because uh I've always told this to to
Gerald and to everyone else who also
works there
um is every single time you do a show I
say assume that that is a 100 new
audience and you sort of learn this when
you're coming up through stand up uh
because you'll be doing like six shows
you know Thursday Two Friday two
Saturday two and you can do really
really well three and then you bomb
because you get a little overconfident
yeah that is a new group of people who
are not familiar with you haven't built
any momentum with them right so I always
want to make sure that people are
getting their money's worth you know
there's there's so much content out
there and sometimes we work in an
industry where yeah it's about Investors
or it's about advertising those are all
fine too uh but I think True North
should always be the the audience and
what it is that they want and how how
you most benefit them and long term if
you do that I think you'll end up doing
well but you know I'm not really a
business guy I'm not like you I was
looking when we were doing research here
I was prepared this guy is like he's
like the Monopoly guy
what do you mean by that I don't just
mean his house now like this guy and
this guy is like crazy wealthy
good he's done all right first yeah he
hasn't done it with it you want to say a
few words for yourself
but you know it's crazy that you're
saying the nervous thing because Tyson
also talked about that you know some of
the best athletes talked about that yeah
were prior to it and it it is a quality
of a great one it's not like uh uh you
know some people are a little bit more
calmer when they go in you know you see
remember like Fedor used to fight Pride
you go and they're like this guy looks
like his he would bring it all the way
down and Kobe would go very ice-like and
that was his style but there are some
that's the other way around either way
you ended up you know remember George
Saint Pierre when he when we had him six
months ago he would get so nervous I was
always afraid of my opponents yes
I'm gonna stand up too and I've you know
I've done two specials I've been on
Kevin Hart special I I think if you
don't have that like but some guys don't
they don't have like zero I think you I
think that I think they're lying he's
right some don't have it no they don't
care they don't care they're those guys
that don't get nervous for a big
audience I don't know I've been around
him I mean good examples like Chuck
Liddell when he would fight uh John
halcon he said he just doesn't get
nervous yeah he just doesn't get nervous
um but I've always been that way yeah do
you get nervous ever like you see you
speak on massive stages you don't get
nervous on podcasts I already know that
but even when you go on stage when
you're speaking in front of big
audiences I I don't know I don't know if
I do at this phase uh uh I don't know if
I do at this phase so that settles it I
guess he's not a great yeah
Mr mediocre 100 millionaire over here
but but I would tell you there are
certain uh times you may depending on
what the climate is so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]